confirmed that the metropolitan police
service will be investigating alleged
breaches of kovit-19 regulations within
government
this is a matter for the police and the
house will understand that i'm not in a
position to comment on the nature or
content of the police investigation
mr speaker i have previously made clear
from from this dispatch box that the
government recognizes and i recognize
the public anxiety and indignation
that it appears as though
the people who have been setting the
rules may not have been following the
rules
and i would like to repeat that
sentiment today
and this is why the prime minister asked
for a cabinet office investigation to
take place
the terms of reference for that
investigation led by the second
permanent secretary at the cabinet
office and the department for leveling
up housing and communities sue grey
have been published and laid in the
library of this house
those terms made clear that as with all
internal investigations mr speaker if
during the course of the work any
evidence emerges of behavior that is
potentially a criminal offence
the matter will be referred to the
police and the cabinet office's work may
be paused mr speaker as the house would
expect there is ongoing contact between
the cabinet office investigation and the
metropolitan police service
however
the cabinet office investigation will
continue its work
i would urge the house to wait for the
findings of that investigation and for
the police to conclude their work
that is important to allow the work to
take place unimpeded
and to protect the rights of all
involved
mr speaker i must emphasize that matters
relating to adherence of the law are
properly a matter for the police to
investigate and the cabinet office will
liaise with them as appropriate
finally mr speaker i can confirm that
the findings of the investigation will
be provided to this honorable house and
made public
mr speaker the house will understand
that there is a limit to what i can say
given this is an ongoing investigation i
also cannot comment on what is now an
ongoing police investigation and
therefore i ask that members of the
house let the investigation run its
course and do not preempt its
conclusions
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker thank you for granting this
urgent question and well well well
all too soon
the minister and i find ourselves here
once again
rather than dealing with the cost of
living crisis impacting on families
we're talking
we're talking about scandals in downing
street again and the members opposite
concerned from their positions but
they're allowing this to happen mr
speaker
two months now cabinet ministers have
been working hard to make sue gray the
most famous woman in britain
in response to every question asked
about the poor conduct bad behavior and
rule breaking culture that this
government has overseen the ministers
have repeatedly told us sue gray is the
answer now there's a police
investigation and the terms of reference
for sue gray set by the prime minister
himself are clear
if any evidence emerges of behavior that
is potentially a criminal offence the
matter will be referred to the police
so it seems mr speaker potential
criminality has been found in downing
street
what a truly damning reflection on our
nation's very highest office
so i ask the minister
given this morning's announcement when
will the sue grey report finally be
published
can he assure the house that the su-grey
report will be published in full not
just
the summary and will the accompanying
evidence be provided and can he clarify
for the house what sue gray and her team
will be doing whilst the police conduct
their investigation
can the minister
can confirm whether the decision to
delay the publication of the sugree
report was made by the metropolitan
police or the government
given this government's record mr
speaker on lost phones missing messages
and minutes
can he assure the house that all
evidence from the great inquiry will be
properly held by the cabinet office
can he clarify
if the chancellor as a resident of
downing street is cooperating fully with
the grey inquiry and if the police
investigation and has he been
interviewed
just weeks ago mr speaker the prime
minister told this house
there was no party
how does the paymaster general explain
that
i know across the country people know
enough they have made up their minds
about the prime minister so when will
his party catch up
[Applause]
well mr speaker i will agree with her
first point her first point was
why aren't we talking about cost of
living
well the prime minister right now is
working on cost of living he's working
on
russia ukraine he is doing those jobs
and the prime minister
is focused on those areas uh
mr speaker i think she also in her
second point forgets that the word
potentially was used the reality of the
matter is that the fact that the police
are investigating the matter does not
draw any conclusions if she looks at the
statement issued by the metropolitan
police commissioner cressida dick
she has said that
uh stressed the fact that the met is in
the the message is investigating does
not mean
that it will necessarily
result in fixed penalty notices in every
instance and to every person involved so
potentially is a key and operative word
and she wants to drop jump to
conclusions
uh but she asks about the details of the
investigation those are of course
matters for the cabinet office and
matters for the police they're not
details which i would be informed i
wouldn't expect to be informed because
the police have independent uh
operational assessment of matters that
are before them and they will conduct
the matter as they see fit
sir edward lee
when europe stands on the brink of war
and there is a cost of living crisis can
we please have a sense of proportion
over the prime minister being given
[Applause]
being given a piece of cake in his own
office by his own staff
i completely agree
mr speaker and on burns day is probably
appropriate we should start with the
line the best laid plans of mice and men
gang after glee or perhaps a line from
the other great scottish writers or
walter scott or what tangled web we
weave when first we practice to deceive
i do wonder mr speaker
now that the police are finally involved
how much more personal humiliation and
indignity will the prime minister be
prepared to endure but perhaps more
importantly how much more of this
embarrassing circus are his colleagues
prepared to tolerate before they act to
remove this man from office because this
isn't going to go away this wound is not
going to heal miraculously by itself and
i'm sure we all know there's an awful
lot more still to come out so can i ask
the minister
at any time
has anyone from the sugary inquiry
contacted the metropolitan police
when did the cabinet office learn first
learn of this police investigation
when does he now expect the sugary
report to be delivered and finally can
he assure this house when it is
delivered that it will be delivered in
full
will be open and will be completely
transparent for every member of this
house to access
well he asks me questions about the
police investigation and i have no
knowledge about that and nor would i
expect or should i have knowledge about
it
and he asks about the publication and i
have already indicated that the findings
of the investigation will be published
karpa
thank you very much um mr speaker um can
i ask the pay master general except he
may not be
able to answer this question now
but can he um
assure the house that he will keep
either he or other ministers will keep
the house posted
about whether the prime minister is
going to be interviewed by the
metropolitan police
either as a witness or as a potential
suspect in this criminal investigation
well i thank him for his question but of
course the police will conduct the
investigation as they do in any case
entirely
at their own discretion and i would not
expect to be informed about that and nor
would the house expect me to be
brian riedel
mr speaker newspaper reports of downing
street staff being told to delete
evidence
of parties from their phones and staff
fearing to give evidence to the sue grey
inquiry
for fear that the pm will see it and
they'll later be recrimination so now
that there's a police investigation
will the pain master general make it
clear
throughout whitehall that all evidence
must be given to the police and will he
undertake to publish the report and
evidence so that we can all see at the
end of this affair that it has been done
[Music]
well i think one can draw a conclusion
if i may say so from the fact that the
cabinet office in their liaison with the
metropolitan police have according to
the metropolitan police commissioner uh
satisfied her that an investigation
should take place and that should give
comfort to those who might otherwise
doubt
the investigation but it is a proper and
due process investigation and as in all
cases where due process should be
followed in the interests of fairness it
would not be appropriate to presuppose
any result of a police investigation or
for that matter of an independent
cabinet office investigation and as i've
already said i would expect the public
the findings to be published in due
course
shall he's far
thank you mr speaker would my right
honourable friend agree with me that it
is a long-standing convention in this
house that when there are independent
inquiries and invest investigations they
are allowed to run their course and
pre-judgments aren't made in this house
given that is the case
and it would be advisable that that
convention be carried on would my right
on friend also agree with me that we
really do need to concentrate on matters
that really affect our constituents on a
day-to-day basis
cost of living energy prices and so on
as well as the fact that there are a
hundred thousand russian troops on the
ukrainian border which threatens
global instability
he makes a powerful point about the
pressing uh international situation
particularly as regards ukraine and
russia and i know the prime minister is
focused on that matter i also understand
the
anxiety and indignation of many who are
uh frustrated by the reports that uh
have been emanating over a course of
many weeks about alleged gatherings in
the downing street area the reality of
the matter is the prime minister is
focused as he has been focused on
delivering for this country as he's
succeeded in delivering vaccines as he
succeeded in delivering on the manifesto
commitments and he'll continue that
laser focus
mr speaker it's clear this government is
now in total meltdown
story after story about covert laws
being broken in number 10
revelations about honourable members
having constituency funding threatened
by government whips
and now a prime minister and his staff
under police investigation
in the midst of a pandemic and a cost of
living crisis
and with europe on the brink of war in
ukraine we cannot go on with this
chaotic government
does the minister accept that the prime
minister's authority is in tatters
will he advise his boss to do the right
thing
in the national interest and resign
[Music]
minister
well i thank him for his advice on
propriety but he will forgive me
[Applause]
he will forgive me if i decline him to
follow him
mr speaker will the minister agree that
anyone taking your view on the prime
minister must take into account the fact
that he's presided over the most
successful vaccination program in the
world
of most other countries in the world
this is absolutely right and we would be
in lockdown now we're not for this prime
minister
[Applause]
anyway
mr speaker
is the prime minister not
simply compounding his previous terrible
mistakes by continuing to deny
culpability leading to an unnecessary
and expensive police inquiry when he
could do the decent thing and resign
minister
i'm sure he would expect fairness to
apply to all in this country whether it
be one of his constituents or one of
mine
and i would hope and expect that he
would not wish to see unfairness to
anyone what we are doing
is we are cooperating at the cabinet
office with a police investigation that
will carry on and take its natural
course
as police investigations invariably take
their natural course in a orderly way
unencumbered by interference from the
executive
david morris
thank you mr speaker
would the pay master general
consider
the metropolitan police or any other
police force looking into the activities
of the leader of the opposition with his
beers party
as far as i can see there's no
difference
what would you say to that famous
buddhist uh
well my honourable friend makes an
interesting point but of course uh
police investigations and uh how they
conduct themselves are operationally
independent i'm sure they will have
heard what he said pete was shot
yeah thank you mr speaker does he not
think that it would be a good idea just
to set up a police special operations
unit and room and number 10 down the
street because we're also looking at
this one they could perhaps look at cash
for honors cash for access ppe for pals
paid advocacy breaking the ministerial
code and just all the other general tory
badness
well i i have to say
a quick google analysis of the snp would
not be particularly
edifying
but what i will say is that despite
noises off this prime minister is
focused on what matters to the british
people
and it's right these matters conclude in
an orderly way
thank you mr speaker i welcome uh this
investigation but you can see you can
see the absolute terror
the terror on the bench is opposite for
this
for for for for them partygate they know
they're up against a prime minister and
a government which has brought youth
unemployment to its lowest ever level
a government and a prime minister led by
the prime minister of course brought us
the astrazeneca uh vaccine has the the
most successful booster program in the
world and that is why opposite absolute
terror that we should focus on policy in
this place focus on the priorities of
the british people and that's why
they're so desperate to land this even
as the inquiry
i agree completely mr speaker the pm
also welcomes the announcement by the
met police today because it's alongside
the sue gray inquiry which the pm set up
i might add that will offer the public
the clarity they need to help draw a
line under these events
andy mcdonald thank you thank you mr
speaker my middlesbrough constituents
have obeyed the rules and done exactly
what the prime minister demanded of them
and abided by the laws that he initiated
doesn't the pay master general
understand that the continued refusal to
do the right and decent thing
only serves to damage our democracy and
tarnish our reputation across the world
and that will not be turned around
until such time as the prime minister
goes and brings this shameful business
to an end
minister no i don't agree with his
characterization
mr speaker does the prime minister does
the paymaster agree
does the paymaster agree
that compared with being interviewed
under caution for flogging peerages as
tony blair was
compared
compared with trying to prosecute a
former first minister of scotland when
they were told there was no evidence to
do so and compared with taking money
from chinese spies that eating a piece
of birthday cake is a relatively minor
offense
my friend makes his point powerfully and
eloquently
go around davis
mr speaker given that
the police investigated and intervened
in a number of parties across london on
the 20th of may can you explain at the
time enormous amounts of booze has been
trundled into number 10 with enormous
house of noise why they didn't intervene
at the time and does that make him fear
about any sort of fudging of this
investigation and perhaps the
another police force should intervene
yeah minister well i'm sorry he chooses
to criticize the metropolitan police i
don't think that um
that would have the support of this
house look the position is mr speaker
that i would ask him to accept that the
metropolitan police and those public
servants who work in government
work
hard
including over a period of major crisis
for this country in the public service
they're devoted to their work they seek
to serve the public in the best way they
can and assumptions ought not to be made
either of police or civil service
impropriety
the matter is subject to investigation
and i would ask him to accept if you
like the default position mr speaker
that persons are innocent unless
otherwise proved that is how it works
jacob young thank you mr speaker last
night nato announced it was putting
troops on standby in response to the
situation in ukraine and in april gas
prices are currently forecast to rise by
more than 50 when the energy price cap
lifts what people in red queen cleveland
want is to move on from this to back
along parties and focus on the real
issues so can you assure me that the
cabinet office will publish sugar's
report as soon as they arrive
[Music]
yeah i completely agree with his uh
position and i would say that uh the the
report of sue gray will be published the
findings of that report uh as soon as
they are available
johnny charlie
yeah
mr speaker and the right honourable
member for gainsborough invited us to
have a sense of proportion in relation
to this matter
can i just refer him to some of the many
one of the many emails i've had from
constituents in edinburgh southwest and
ask the minister what he thinks about it
this constituent said to me if i hadn't
followed the clover restrictions like
the prime minister
i would have driven to norfolk to see my
mom after she broke her leg and had to
stay in a nursing home i would have been
able to go south to prepare her house
i could have helped cook and clean for
her while we found suitable local carers
i could have sung her happy birthday
from the hospital grounds while she
recovered from the covet she caught from
her carer
and i could have been with her when she
died a few days later
82
and alone in a ward of strangers
what should i say to my constituent
should i tell him to have a sense of
proportion
[Music]
apologize to him and all the other
people across the united kingdom who
kept the rules when the prime minister
and his mates didn't
i would
invite her to offer to her constituent
my
abject sorrow
and condolences for his loss
there is nothing that i can say
to bring back
that loss but what i can say we're just
going to keep an eye on this famous
store the prime minister is expected in
the house of commons very very soon to
make a statement about ukraine uh we
will bring it to you live as he leaves
number 10 but in the meantime
let's listen in to what's happening in
the house of commons
leading the world
in our arrangements around the pandemic
and where the prime minister will
continue to focus on those priorities
absolutely
i welcome the metropolitan police
inquiry and express surprise that it
wasn't announced earlier in his previous
role as attorney general the pay master
general will be more familiar than most
with the covet 19 regulations and the
fixed penalty notices that have been
issued can he confirm that they are
summary offenses normally investigated
within six months and that the burden of
proof is beyond reasonable doubt
minister
well
i'm grateful to my honourable friend
face question um i would prefer not to
get into the legal position as he can uh
imagine but what i would say is that uh
i would expect as would everyone the
police to conduct their investigation uh
and they will do so at a time that uh no
doubt is in accordance with their own
procedures and protocols he is right to
raise the fact that there will be uh
tests uh evidence and burden of proof
and it is always right of course that a
person in this country is innocent
unless or until they be proven guilty
i'm expecting to run this to about 115
so we can help each other by speeding
through debbie abrahams
the speaker um what assessment has been
undertaken on the damage that partygate
has
uh on our economy on inward investment
and on the trust that the british people
have with this government
minister
well can i can i invite she asks what
assessment has been made
can i invite uh the house to note that
this prime minister
held a cabinet meeting
the day after his own mother died
that he was working just weeks after he
himself
had been released from intensive care in
hospital
that he has led the world on astrazeneca
on vaccine availability and we would
still be
in a lockdown situation if it were not
for him
so i would invite her to accept those
points are the points that will really
focus the mind
[Music]
thank you mr speaker um given that there
are ongoing investigations by sue gray
and the metropolitan police at this time
and we await those results does my right
or honorable friend not agree that this
urgent question itself is a vexatious
waste of everybody's time
the allowance of um
urgent questions can i just say to the
minister
i'm sure he's not going to question my
judgment because i'm the person that
grants him and i'm sure he'd like to
withdraw that step and it does need
answering
mr speaker at your behest i withdraw the
question absolutely
right i'll listen clueless
thank you very much mr speaker
one of my constituents billie jean was
in touch billy jean was in university
well boris johnson uh we just uh missed
the actual shot of him coming out number
10 fortunately but as he got into the
car you may have heard the uh
the delicate tones of our deputy
political editor sam coates throwing
some questions at him or maybe it wasn't
sam um
can he survive was the question uh it's
been a really difficult morning for the
prime minister let's bring in sam coates
now
sam you've gleaned lots of information
in the last few minutes including the
fact that when those ministers came out
of cabinet this morning they were
amongst the last to know about the
metropolitan police's investigation
that's right jay no answer there from my
question to boris johnson about whether
or not he can survive this police
investigation that's the question many
tory mps are asking also questions about
the handling of the even this morning
and how downing streets are approaching
it we understand that there is quite
some irritation among certain members of
the cabinet
because boris johnson went into today's
meeting of what's supposed to be his top
team and didn't tell them what was being
announced while they were in there now
cabinet ministers of course have to hand
in their phones before they go in the
cabinet room and apparently at the end
of cabinet boris johnson eluded for the
need to get on with the job he did not
tell them that he knew that this morning
cressida dick the commissioner of the
metropolitan police would be announcing
an investigation into his downing street
that is a fairly extraordinary admission
now i've just been in the lobby briefing
for
journalists asking about this number 10
said that the issue was too sensitive uh
i also understand they weren't quite
sure of the format in which the
announcement were made or exactly the
terms of uh that it was going to come in
although they did know it's going to be
this morning but that means that boris
johnson chose
not to tell his cabinet this morning so
when you saw pictures of cabinet
ministers streaming out of that door
they were facing the bewildering shouts
of journalists about whether or not
boris johnson can survive a police
investigation they many of them didn't
exactly know what we were talking about
because they were pretty much the last
people in britain to know now there's
lots of information coming out right now
particularly from that lobby briefing
and from the uh statement in the house
of commons
uh we're getting critical information in
particular uh about the sugray report
now i am told by sources that the
metropolitan police are quite happy for
the whole thing to be published but it
appears that government somewhere in
government possibly the investigation
department uh possibly downing street
we're still trying to get to the bottom
of it have decided that we're not going
to get the full thing instead we might
get uh a partial bit of the sugar report
on the investigations that the police
have decided not to take up in other
words uh the bits where it's less
serious so we might get a bit of a
sugray report in the coming days
but certainly not the stuff that's at
the heart of the allegations that are
being investigated by police an
investigation that's going to require
the metropolitan police to reinterview
all the witnesses that see great
interviews
but i think you get a sense of that
feeling of political uncertainty one of
the questions i asked uh at that
briefing was whether or not boris
johnson knows exactly what sue gray told
the police what did sue gray hand over
to the police that triggered this
investigation announcement today
boris johnson doesn't know boris johnson
has not seen what sue grey handed to the
police so
in many ways downing street's slightly
flying blind here they don't know
exactly what the police have got who
said what to whom
they know the broad allegations and of
course know what they did but the
political uncertainty this morning is
massive for the prime minister and it
will not have endeared him he will not
have endeared himself to his cabinet has
not endeared himself to his cabinet by
keeping this political bombshell that he
knew all the way through cabinet to
himself
and sam in terms of of the wagons that
are circling david davis
l would already have put on on record
their feelings about the prime minister
and again since the metropolitan police
report but
it seems to be certainly
quiet from a lot of people are a lot of
people just now holding back to just
sense the lay of the land
yes i think that the scarier sound in
politics is silence when people aren't
coming out to defend you there is the
potential that things are going really
quite sharply wrong the reason for that
is that tory mps have to make a lot of
calculations in a very short order
essentially they have to work out if
they back boris johnson but then he's
later found guilty or issued with a
penalty notice is he then in the clear
because he's got the political backing
or does the fact of a legal judgment
against him when he was the one setting
the rules mean that he'd have to rely uh
resign then so could they back him now
but then lose him later that's one big
question that tory mps are going to have
to face another one they're going to
have to face is just how long is this
investigation gonna
sort of cloud over them uh how long is
the how long the police going to take uh
we have precedent and police
investigations into downing street and
because of the need to do the job
thoroughly and
need to tick every box and the
sensitivity involved they take months
the cash for honors investigation took
uh a year or so to complete and that
ended up without the crown prosecution
service uh pressing charges uh so
they've got to work out how long they
want this to go on for whether or not a
police exoneration can be expected even
in the median term
and whether or not they just have enough
confidence in boris johnson given the
sort of news tsunami that we've had just
in the last 36 hours with the
resignation of one of boris johnson's
ministers uh with them having to uh do a
u-turn and offer an investigation
effectively into whether or not racist
comments were made in downing street
about a muslim uh female muslim minister
and then last night that accusation that
boris johnson did celebrate his party
with a cake his wife and his designer in
the cabinet room when he turned i
believe it was 56
the speed with which bad news is hitting
boris johnson is also another
calculation that will
have to be made by tory mps how much
more of this can they put up with how
much is there an end in sight or is this
just going to go on and on and on in a
way that
really hits the political fortunes of
the party uh they what they hope will uh
win them at the next election in a way
that just means that they can't
okay sam thanks a lot for bringing us
all those new developments let's return
to the commons uh we are still having
this debate uh about the metropolitan
police's intervention but we are
expecting the prime minister himself to
speak about ukraine at quarter past
johnson thank you mr speaker the home
affairs select committee has been
following the issue of the consistency
of enforcement of covid regulations as
we are well aware
that of how failure to do so can erode
public trust
and the home affairs select committee
will have an opportunity to ask
questions of the metropolitan
commissioner soon but as the police have
primary responsibility for criminal
investigations in this country does the
minister think that it would have been
much better to have passed this on to
the metropolitan police as soon as these
allegations came to light and that we
would now be concluding that
investigation by the metropolitan police
and he would have to stop coming to this
house of commons to defend the prime
minister
[Music]
well minister i know that uh the
honourable lady is a very fair um
chair of the home affairs select
committee and she will acknowledge that
the police have their job to do it is
not a matter for the government
to
or the executive to refer matters that
has been done by the cabinet office
independently as part of their
investigation and as to the length of
the police investigation we have no idea
how long that will be
right what
thank you mr speaker it's clearly
correct that the police should
investigate any suspicions of breaches
of uh the law regardless of who may be
involved have my right to my friend
assure this house and the country
that sue grey is being left to conduct
her investigation independently and
freely and that there are no barriers to
her passing any information she may find
that is relevant onto the police about
any potential rule breaking
minister yes i can confirm that and in
fact the the fact that
uh
the cabinet office has passed matters to
the metropolitan police is proven by
today's news
oh williams
thank you mr speaker
will the minister explain to his last
quick witted colleagues
that claimed good works on kovid are no
excuse for breaking the law
no one is proved to have done what he
alleges
thank you mr speaker
it is absolutely right for there to be a
full investigation into these matters
just as it was in terms of the police
investigation into the cash for honours
scandal under the blair government and
can my right honourable friend assure me
that the police will of course be given
full cooperation in these matters as
they have been during the cabinet office
investigation process minister
i can assure my friend that uh full
cooperation will be accorded to the
police uh as and if they ask for it i'm
just brendan mcneil thank you very much
uh mr speaker it's quite clear that even
after admissions the prime minister
doesn't want to leave a 10 downing state
but don't we face the possibility in the
uk that uk's pm might eventually be
leaving 10 earnings in police handcuffs
no
justin
justin mothers
thank you mr speaker on the 8th of
december the prime minister told this
house and i quote there was no party
paragraph one through the ministerial
code says any anyone who knowingly must
leave the house will be expected to
resign so why is the prime minister
still in his job
minister
well if if a group of people gather for
work whilst at work they take cake for
10 minutes and everyone working is
permitted reasonable
breaks as a as a part of their working
day so that's one possible
interpretation 10 minutes of eating cake
and wishing someone a happy birthday
would not a party make but it is a
matter for police investigation and that
is now what's happening shalom thank you
mr speaker i thank the pay master
general for his response to the
questions each day and now he does seem
to feel like there are new reports of a
suspected lockdown breach i'm pleased
however that investigations are on their
way underway by the met police can the
pay master general
confirm that any and all findings from
these investigations will be disclosed
to the media for public reassurance and
that this will be the case for all
potential reports of breaches that may
yet come before sue grey's
investigations are included and that
justice will be done mister
i can assure him that the findings of
sue gray's report will be put before
this house
alex david
mr speaker once again the pay master
general has been forced to come to the
dispatch box to defend the indefensible
and no one is buying it honesty
transparency and leadership should be at
the heart of this country's government
but it is severely lacking so will the
prime minister now come to this house to
set the record straight tell us exactly
what gatherings and parties he attended
at downing street or better yet will he
just resign
well i know she wishes to make political
points mr speaker but uh
it's kind of hard to focus on my comfort
but i'm not forced to do anything i'm
here because i
know the prime minister
is entitled to the same justice as
anyone else and as far as uh the
opposition are concerned mr speaker it's
unedifying to make party political
points over this matter the focus of
this government is on the primary
concerns which are
cost of living
employment the economy
the situation in ukraine and russia
whilst the police and cabinet office
conclude their investigation yeah bob
rakely
thank you mr speaker the police were
asked to enforce kobe rules across the
country and they faced difficult
challenges in doing so to keep us all
safe
issuing tens of thousands of fines to
people who broke the rules even those
gathering for birthdays
does the minister believe the prime
minister is above the law because my
constituents are asking why these events
took place disregarding the rules and i
say to those opposite who attacked this
business today these matters do concern
our constituents they do
no one is above the law in this country
hendry
thank you
mr speaker the pmaster general doesn't
want to speak about the specifics of
this investigation so can i ask him for
all the dodgy coronavirus contracts the
cash for honors from the tories the
stated intention to break international
law illegally programming parliament and
the many other crimes and misdemeanors
of this government does the minister
find it a tad ironic that it is the
parties where they demonstrated their
contempt for the public that has finally
prompted the police to investigate
if there's anything ironic it is the
scottish national party
can i remind the minister it started
with a joke about a fictional party
during a dummy press conference then the
faux outrage from the prime minister who
was angry about this joke all the while
there were parties lots of them and he
was at some of them there's a mountain
of evidence of troop twisting rule
bending and law breaking and it lands at
the feet of the man at the top so why is
this minister still defending the
indefensible
minister i see the honourable gentleman
wishes to be judged jury and executioner
but no one in this house would give him
that position what matters is justice
justice for all and that will apply in
this case as it does it in any other way
we now come to the statement
[Music]
[Applause]
i now call the prime minister
prime minister
thank you mr speaker mr speaker a few
weeks ago i commissioned an independent
inquiry into a series of events in
downey street in the cabinet office as
well as some other whitehall departments
that may have constituted potential
breaches of the covid regular